once translation has initiated
elongation can occur elongation
specifically of the polypeptide chain so
after initiation we have the formulated
Athenian tRNA hanging around in the
ribosome ready ready for elongation to
occur so it's specifically in the p-site
there are three sides of the ribosome
the a site the P site and the ESI and
before going on it must talk about what
each of those are so the P site sends
four peptidyl and the reason why that's
important is because the peptidyl site
or the P site is where the existing
peptide chain will be so now initially
the peptide chain is only slightly metal
chain is just one amino acid the a site
is the acceptor site and the acceptor
site is where the next amino acyl tRNA
lines so that's a site here that's
acceptor site then the last site the e
site is the exit site and the exit site
is where the empty tRNA leaves so how
does elongation happen well this next
amino acid so this here is the
formulated by finding the first amino
acid in prokaryotes so this thing is
going to have a free amino terminus so
this next amino acyl tRNA comes in and
it goes to the a site and it binds in
the a site and this is binding of course
according to the codon here on the mRNA
strand this cuz I wanna draw it might be
too small this amino acid will be or
this amino acid attached to this tRNA
will bind here according to the codon
and anticodon base pairing here between
the mRNA and the tRNA once this tRNA is
bound then we have the elongation step
occur the actual elongation step so what
is the elongation step
consists of well amino acid number two
the next amino acid its amino group I'm
sure to put amino group amino group will
act as a nucleophile and attack the
carboxy groups the carboxyl carbon on
the previous amino acid in order to form
a covalent bond so in this case the
previous amino acid is the formulated
methane it's initially in the P site so
the amino acid number two its amino its
amino group will attack the formal
formulated Metheny causing it to join
and covalently bond so that there is the
actual elongation step this elongation
step is catalyzed by an enzyme called
peptidyl transferase and this process
costs one GTP so once that covalent bond
forms between the amino acid number two
and the formula defining the covalent
bond holding the formulator I'm
assigning to this trna breaks so then
what we have is this so this tRNA in the
P site is now empty and the existing
polypeptide chain is in the acceptor
site that's not what's supposed to
happen the existing polypeptide chain is
going to supposed to be in the P site so
what's going to happen is both of these
are going to shift over and move once
one codon space they're going to shift
over our space this way so they're going
to shift over one codon that step is
translocation or yeah translocation so
that translocation step costs one GTP as
well so what ends up happening is that
that empty tRNA is now in the e site and
it's ready to exit so this thing can now
leave and what's left it's just the
existing polypeptide chain is in the p
site and now this next amino acid is
ready to bind at the a site
so we're back to where we started from
so now the V process can happen again as
many times as necessary in order to form
that that peptide chain so how is this
different in eukaryotes well in
eukaryotes
there's no formulated in my thigh 18
it's just the Massiah Neen and the other
difference is that instead of having a
70s ribosome there's an 80s sy ribosome
other than that pretty much the same I
hope that video is helpful one last
thing I am a tutor if you live in
Southern California feel free to contact
me via email I move university at
gmail.com see the description below for
more details thank you for watching